an incalculable advantage that the
americans had
i can express in two words
george washington
declaring independence was the easy part
defeating the mightiest military power
in the world
that was another matter
the united states such as they were this
united united states went into this
conflict with huge
and fairly obvious disadvantages
but all was not lost because the
americans did enjoy certain very real
advantages
for one thing they had only to play
defense
they needed not to win every battle they
needed not to win any battles so long as
they were able to keep the war going
long enough to exhaust the patience and
willingness to fight of the british
opponent another advantage an
incalculable advantage that the
americans had
i can express in two words george
washington
they had the person of george washington
a man of such
fine and admired widely universally
admired character
and
military skills political savvy
he commanded the loyalty of nearly all
americans and thus served as a unifying
force when he was made
commander-in-chief of the revolutionary
american forces
he
signaled his
willingness to play this role by
appearing at the second continental
congress in philadelphia wearing his
military uniform
so he was
ready to play
and from june 1775 on was commander in
chief of the continental army
[Music]
he received the position and accepted it
on the condition that he received no pay
for it
that was the kind of guy george
washington was he was
charismatic courageous
selfless tireless
he was not a world-class intellect like
jefferson but he was always learning he
had a great deal of practical and
prudential wisdom
the greatest challenge that washington
would face was simply one of recruiting
and holding together a credible army
this was not an easy job
there was a sense of fragility about the
whole enterprise so that the morale and
willingness to serve of soldiers
waxed and waned depending on the
circumstances in the field and
weather conditions which were very
important in the american revolution in
august of 1776 not long after the the
declaration he had 28 000 men under his
command
by december that number had shrunk
to 3 000.
what had happened was that the troops
had been driven
from new york new york city by british
regulars
back and back and back until they ended
up in pennsylvania
the army's morale was bad it was always
unstable it was always hostage to events
to successive
peaks and valleys in the uh and
consequent hope and despair
depending on how the war effort was
going
washington through all this had to keep
a cool head he had to not be
too influenced either by
the giddiness of success or the
despondency of failure
as it turned out the winter that winter
1776 to 77 was an exceptionally bad
winter
and made for a gloomy time of
discouragement
uh fortunately for the patriot cause uh
tom paine
chose at that time to write yet another
contribution to the war effort a series
of pamphlets called the american crisis
which uh the most famous lines from that
which some of you may have heard
go like this at the beginning
he says these are the times that try
men's souls
the summer soldier and the sunshine
patriot will in this crisis shrink from
the service of his country but he that
stands it now deserves the love and
thanks of man and woman
yes he conceded that things look very
bad but the harder the conflict the more
glorious the triumph paine
put it just the way washington would
have liked to been able to and george
washington ordered that payne's words
from the american crisis be read to his
troops who were suffering through this
bitter winter
and they had the desired effect of
rousing them to a new burst of fighting
spirit
and then on christmas night of 1776
washington struck back
he led a force through snow and sleet
across the delaware river you've all
seen the painting of that which is not
exactly historically accurate but
who cares
it's a beautiful painting
and he surprised at dawn a sleeping
force of hessians the hated hessians at
trenton in new jersey
a week later his forces had a similar
triumph at princeton
two small victories bought
reason for hope uh that they could be
argues of good things to come
it appeared the american forces would
not be defeated quickly as the british
had hoped
thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore all of
hillsdale college's online courses
they're free and for everyone who loves
to learn